wann und wie man gehen will das belastet
ihr leben manchmal noch mehr als die
krankheit selbst sagen sie deshalb sind
vier sterbenskranke menschen vor gericht
gezogen
ob sie erfolg haben ob ihre klagen die
rechtslage zur sterbehilfe in
deutschland verändern werden
das erfahren wir in gut zehn minuten wir
schauen mal rüber in den großen saal des
bundesverfassungsgerichts hier in
karlsruhe
sie sehen er füllt sich langsam den
punkt 10 uhr werden die richtern und
richter hier ihr urteil zur sterbehilfe
verkünden
und weil das für sie für mich für uns
alle eine entscheidung von so
grundlegender bedeutung ist nehmen wir
uns die kommenden 40 minuten um das
urteil zu verstehen zu hinterfragen und
zu diskutieren
[Musik]
lebe gerne aber wenn der zeitpunkt
gekommen ist wo man mit lebensqualität
nicht mehr gegeben ist dann möchte ich
nicht mehr leben dann möchte ich sterben
und zwar dann wenn ich es möchte und im
rahmen der legalität hat man das in
zukunft wieder kann selbst bestimmt sein
leben beenden mit der hilfe von ärzten
darüber haben die richterinnen und
richter hier am bundesverfassungsgericht
entschieden und deshalb senden sie sie
heute live aus karlsruhe live vom
bundesverfassungsgericht denn dieses
urteil heute kann die rechtslage in
deutschland und damit das leben und
sterben in deutschland grundlegend
verändern und damit herzlich willkommen
liebe zuschauern im zuschauer zu einem
zdf spezial zur sterbehilfe freut mich
dass sie dabei sind die würde des
menschen ist unantastbar so steht es im
grundgesetz direkt bendis aufschlagen
erster artikel erster satz
und genau dieser artikel dieser
grundsatz der steht hier heute
mittelpunkt denn was am ende des lebens
als würde ich empfunden wird dazu gibt
es sehr unterschiedliche ansichten
mit seinem urteil heute wird das
bundesverfassungsgericht nichts
geringeres als genau das fest wegen
festlegen was ein würdevolles sterben
und leben im sinne unseres grundgesetzes
ist und ich freue mich sehr dieses
wegweisende urteil die erwartungen daran
und die beurteilung des ausgangs mit
diesen gästen zu diskutieren live aus
mal aus seinem wohnzimmer in nordrhein
westfalen ist uns helmut feldmann
zugeschaltet er ist der grund wieso wir
heute hier stehen er hat dieses urteil
erstritten er kann aus gesundheitlichen
gründen nicht selber hier im
bundesverfassungsgericht dabei sein
deshalb freuen wir uns umso mehr dass
sie heute hier das urteil mit uns live
verfolgen werden herr feldmann dass es
ihr tag und wir freuen uns dass sie hier
in unserer runde mit uns diskutieren
werden
frau breuckmann jetzt ist auch in der
unis katholische theologin und selber
aktiv als sterbebegleiterin kennt die
hospizarbeit aus ihrem alltag und sie
sagt die rechtslage so wie sie aktuell
ist das ein sterbenskranker nicht
wiederholt die hilfe eines arztes in
anspruch nehmen kann oder sterbenskranke
nicht wiederholt ärzte dazu auffordern
können ihnen beim sterben zu helfen
das ist richtig so da widerspricht
professor taupitz er ist einer der
führenden medizinrechtler in deutschland
und er sagt wörtlich die rechtslage so
wie sie aktuell ist ist eine katastrophe
er fällt man wir wollen aber mit ihnen
starten weil das ihr tag ist ihr urteil
ist deshalb sagen sie uns was erwarten
sie von dem urteil heute also erwarte
von dem urteil heute dass es keinen
bestand haben wird der paragraph 217 stw
das erwarte ich erwarte nicht dass
gekippt wird aber ich erwarte zu 80
prozent dass dieses urteil keinen
bestand haben wird und das die
sterbehilfe in deutschland erlaubt wird
wie sie wünschen sich dass für sich
persönlich was was wollen sie hier
erreichen
ja ich bin sehr schwer krank ich leide
unter copd und lungenemphysem und das
schon seit 22 jahren das hat sich aber
verstehen und einer der noch nie eine
luftnot attacke erlebt hat kann sich
nicht vorstellen was das bedeutet das
ist das schlimmste was sich was man so
erleben kann und das ist der punkt wo
ich meine schwester hat sterben sehen
und so möchte ich nicht sterben das war
schon damals mein wille mich damit zu
beschäftigen und ich habe mich intensiv
damit auseinandergesetzt und ich bin
dann 2012 in die sternbilder eingetreten
aus diesem grunde weil ich damals war es
noch legal durch den paragrafen 217 stgb
ist das ja verboten worden und ich halte
das für rechtswidrig und für inhuman und
ich möchte das ist
in deutschland wieder erlaubt wird die
sterbehilfe in der relation gesehen zu
anderen ländern zu den benelux ländern
der schweiz und andere
dort ist es erlaubt und ich kann nicht
nachvollziehen dass dieses gesetz über
den bundestag so entstanden ist und ich
respektiere dieses gesetz auch nicht von
akzeptanz darf gar nicht die rede
er fällt man um einmal besser zu
verstehen wie ihre situation ist meine
kollegen hatten sie in mal besucht und
wir schauen uns mal an was ihre
beweggründe sind helmut feldmann liebt
das leben und fürchtet sich vor dem
sterben der 73 jährige hat eine
unheilbare lungenkrankheit noch bekommt
der luft doch er weiß nicht wie lange
noch
wenn man austherapiert es gibt es keine
hilfe mehr
und dann erstickt man qualvoll
seine schwester starb an der gleichen
krankheit helmut feldmann will das nicht
erleben
sein größter wunsch ein leben ohne die
angst vor dem qualvollen tod ein mittel
das in friedlich sterben ließe könnte
ihm diese angst nehmen
ich würde mich dieses mittel wir sorgen
dass es mit dem in meine wohnung würde
mich ins bett legen oder hier auf die
codes und meine tochter würde meine hand
halten wollen und dann würde ich langsam
das mitnehmen und den würde ich langsam
einschlafen das genau dass es mein
wunsch dass mittel gibt es doch ärzte
dürfen es nicht verschreiben
helmut feldmann versteht nicht warum der
staat ihn so in bedrängnis bringt von
einem turm zu springen dazu weg zu feige
so einfach ist das helmut feldmann will
gehen können ohne andere zu erschrecken
will selbst bestimmen über sein ende
er fragt man jetzt selbst bestimmen über
sein lebensende
wieso wollen sie herrn feldmann diesen
wunsch verwehren das ist doch
verständlich eigentlich ja ich denke
erst mal geht es nicht darum menschen zu
verurteilen für diesen wunsch ich denke
dass wir alle weit weg aber ich glaube
die diskussion die ja heute
hier ganz rasant geführt werden soll
geht darum zu was greift der staat und
das grundsätzlich zu legitimieren oder
eben nicht und das gesetz gibt bislang
eben her wie das 2005 entschieden ist
dass wir davon abstand nehmen dass ärzte
dazu legitimiert sind diesen suizid zu
sie zu verhelfen
aber das führt jetzt zu einer situation
erfährt man dass beschrieben ich kann
vom turm springen dazu bin ich zu feige
und eine andere möglichkeit habe ich
nicht wieso wollen sie eben eine andere
möglichkeit nicht geben
also sie haben soeben in der
anmoderation schon gesagt ich komme aus
dem haus geschlichen kontext und ich
glaube wir sind noch nicht damit am ende
mit den anderen möglichkeiten die es
gibt
ich glaube das worauf die diskussion
momentan sehr stark konzentriert und das
halte ich für gefährlich ist
ausschließlich um er auf den
todeszeitpunkt und ich glaube also das
ist das was ich aus plötzlicher sicht
immer wieder versucht deutlich zu machen
der sterbeprozess der sterbe weg ist
durch so viele
unterstützungsmöglichkeiten mehr zu
begleiten
da sind wir noch lange nicht beim
todeszeitpunkt an sich sondern bei dem
sterbe weg der vielen patienten ich
denke eigentlich auch wie eine feldmann
angst macht vor dem unverhofften vor dem
was quasi aussagen
man meldet sich gar nicht
also frau waren ich muss da
widersprechen
ich sah in dortmund in vier hospize aber
mit viel palliativ ärzten gesprochen mit
meinen unterlagen die dem mann gesagt
haben ich werde also austherapiert da
gibt es nichts mehr
und dann habe ich gefragt was man machen
könnte ich habe natürlich keine angst
vor dem sterben aber ich habe angst
qualvoll zu ersticken wie es bald meiner
schwester der fall war die gleiche
erkrankung hatte und gerade das ist der
punkt wo ich muss ich leider
unterbrechen gleich wieder ein aber die
richter ziehen einen wir schauen jetzt
im großen saal des
bundesverfassungsgericht weil wir
bewegen uns zu auf 10 uhr und den großen
mann in der mitte können sie im
mittelpunkt behalten das ist der
präsident des bundesverfassungsgerichts
andreas voßkuhle und er ist auch
präsident des zweiten senats
und das urteil verkünden
in wenigen minuten allerdings wird der
zunächst löffler die sitzung des zweiten
senats des bundesverfassungsgerichts zur
verkündung einer entscheidung in dem
verfahren über die
verfassungsbeschwerden römisch erstens
arabisch erstens das herrenhemd feldmann
habe ich zwei des herrn dr horst lenz 2
bvr 23 47 aus 2015 römisch zweiter des
vereins sterbe hilfe deutschland ev
hamburg 26
alle beteiligten entscheiden
menschenwürdig sterben
34 diese zeit nehmen wir uns nochmal
über nah ans oder eben aufgehört habe
ich drüber sterbehilfe zu diskutieren
und werden dann sobald es zum urteil
kommt die darüber gehen in den
gerichtssaal werden dass sie die ganze
zeit live im auge behalten und dann
hören wie das verfassungsgericht
entschieden hat er feldmann wir waren
gerade bei ihnen und sie haben ihrer v
mit der hospizarbeit geschildert bitte
fahren sie fort was welche verfahren ich
halte für hospize halte ich für
erforderlich für menschen die gerne
dahin wollen das ist auch wichtig für
mich ich möchte aber nicht dorthin und
es gibt viele andere menschen die das
aufnehmen möchten
um darauf zurückzukommen was sie erzählt
mir gesagt haben dass sich also dass es
keine einigung die keine therapie mehr
gibt dass ich aus therapiert bin und
dass meine ängste dass man da more
führung geben könnte und dann habe ich
gesagt und wenn die panik größer wird
bei erstickungsanfälle ja dann könnten
wir noch mal mehr führung gehen
da sein und dann stirbt man da hat man
mir gesagt ja dann steht man da habe ich
gesagt das ist nichts anderes als
sterbehilfe nur auf einer legalen ebene
und so ist es auch und das ist die
realität und das wird von infra
brückmann verschwiegen und das wird auch
verschwiegen was die palliativ er zu mir
gesagt haben dass also ein viertel
der patienten die dort sind auch die
schmerzen erleiden in den man nicht
helfen kann weil dieses schmerzmittel
dort nicht anschlagen und auch das wird
verschwiegen
also ich habe die erfahrung gemacht weil
es hier von vier palliativ ärzten die
mir das gleiche dargelegt haben und
erklärt haben frau fragt man jetzt
wollen sie direkt heraus medien gerne
also ich kann natürlich nicht aus
medizinischer perspektive sprechen weil
ich kein arzt in sondern theologin kann
aber wohl sagen dass die erfahrungen die
wir im restlichen kontext nach mit
relativ ärzten und auch den
entsprechenden patienten dass die
möglichkeit der begleittherapie sehr
hoch ist und das natürlich eine
indikation stehen muss und dann die
symptomkontrolle sehr dezidiert und vor
allem sehr individuell laufen muss ich
kann das nicht beurteilen wer erfährt
man wie bei ihnen die gespräche mit den
pellets medizin angelaufen sind mein
wunsch wäre natürlich dass es optimal
ist wenn sie sagen wir sind an sie
herangetreten aber nicht im hospiz im
selber quasi lebens gewesen oder
überhaupt wohnhaft gewesen
dann kann es sein dass möglicherweise da
die schwierigkeit gelegenheit weil sowas
gibts natürlich stationäre hospize immer
auch beanspruchen einen unmittelbaren
eine unmittelbare beziehung zu
platzieren und das ist ein schlüsselwort
zudem affleck später nachkommen profess
ab jetzt was sagen sie es ist kern des
konflikts dass viele sagen hospiz ist
der ort wo schmerzen genommen werden
können und man braucht im grunde gar
nicht die beihilfe zum suizid ja aber es
ist anerkannter rechtsprechung seit
langem dass jeder patient das recht hat
eine bestimmte medizinische massnahmen
abzulehnen
und da fällt man hat völlig recht dass
er selbstbestimmt entscheiden möchte
welche maßnahmen man ihnen anbietet und
er sie dann in anspruch nimmt und wir
auf welche maßnahmen er verzichtet und
wenn er sagt das hospiz ist für mich
keine alternative dann hat er das gute
recht dazu und wenn gesagt wird ja als
man muss erstmal die justiz hospizen er
ausbauen weiter ausbauen
dann hilft das handheld man doch
überhaupt nicht also ich bin der
auffassung dass das
selbstbestimmungsrecht des menschen auch
ein selbstbestimmtes sterben umfasst und
dass dazu auch die möglichkeit gehören
muss von anderen hilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen soweit sie das mit ihrem gewissen
vereinbaren können also es gibt
sicherlich keinen anspruch geben
niemanden ich kann nicht von ihnen
fordern dass sie mir helfen beim sterben
aber wenn es jemand freiwillig an einer
arzt oder eine andere person dann sollte
das auch möglich sein
wir schauen uns noch mal an wir haben
eine grafik vorbereitet zu paragraph 217
strafgesetzbuch denn dieser
straftatbestand der steht im mittelpunkt
der entscheidung die gleich kommen
werden und deswegen wollen wir uns
diesen straftatbestand noch mal ganz
genau anschauen und schauen was da steht
weil es gleich darum gehen wird da steht
werden der absicht die selbsttötung
eines anderen zu fördern diesem hierzu
geschäftsmäßig die gelegenheit gewährt
wird mit freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei
jahren oder mit geldstrafe bestraft das
ist geltendes recht aktuell in
deutschland wichtig für das verständnis
ist geschäftsmäßig ist die hilfe auch
ohne bezahlung es reicht die
bereitschaft ist wiederholt zu tun und
straflos ist aber beispielsweise die
einmalige hilfe durch angehörige oder
freunde oder wenn es ein arzt in einer
einmaligen ausnahme situation tut das
ist so ist die rechtslage aktuell in
deutschland professor toppits was ist
das problem nie so sagen sie das ist
eine katastrophe diese rechtslage so wie
sie es ja ich meine bei meinem arzt aus
gewissensgründen in einer bestimmten
situation entscheidet ich möchte meinen
patienten weil ich seine motive
respektiere weil ich sie akzeptiere
möchte ich ihm helfen dass er
selbstbestimmte sterben kann dann wird
der arzt in einer vergleichbaren
situation aufgrund seines gewissens doch
wieder genauso entscheiden also eine
gewissensentscheidung ist per se auf
wiederholung angelegt denn das gewissen
schlecht ja nicht heute so und morgen
anders sondern in vergleichbaren
situationen muss man aufgrund seines
gewissens immer wieder gleich handeln
und das ist das problem mit diesen
paragraphen frau bergmann geht sie sagen
aber so soll es bleiben wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe wieso also ich hätte
genau da an weil ich genau das eben auch
für problematisch erachte und klar und
glaube dass wir davor schützen müssen
was wir nicht tun sollten ist die
atmosphäre eines misstrauens gegenüber
erste zu kommen das halte ich für
gefährlich
aber was ich schon für wichtig erachte
ist dass wir gesamtgesellschaftlich
davor schützen dass die so zieht diese
quasi zur norm wird zu einer scheinbaren
therapie zu erscheinen das ist ein
urteil verkündet die verfahren werden
zur gemeinsamen entscheidungen
verrückten paragraph 17 des
strafgesetzbuches in der fassung des
gesetzes zur strafbarkeit der
geschäftsmäßigen förderung der
selbsttötung vom dritten dezember 2015
verletzt die beschwerdeführer
zur römisch erster arabisch erstens will
ich erstens arabisch zweiter und römisch
sechster arabisch fünftens in ihrem
grundrecht aus artikel 2 absatz 1 in
verbindung mit artikel 1 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes die beschwerdeführer zu
grödig zweitens und römisch drittens
arabisch zweitens in ihrem grundrecht
aus artikel 2 absatz 1 des grundgesetzes
die beschwerdeführer zur römisch
drittens arabisch drittens römisch
drittens arabisch fünfter und römisch
jacksons arabisch zweitens in ihren
grundrechten aus artikel 2 absatz 1 und
das artikel 2 absatz 2 satz 2 in
verbindung mit artikel 104 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes so viele beschwerdeführer
zur römisch drittens arabisch sechster
bestimmten service fünftens arabisch
erstens bis römisch fünftens arabisch
viertens und reflexen des arabisch
drittens in ihren grundrechten aus
artikel 12 absatz 1 und aus artikel 2
absatz 2 satz 2 in verbindung mit
artikel 104 absatz 1 des grundgesetzes
die vorschrift ist mit dem grundgesetz
unvereinbar und nichtig die
verfassungsbeschwerde des
beschwerdeführers zu römisch sechstens
arabisch erstens und der
beschwerdeführerin zur römisch viertens
arabisch treffens haben sich durch deren
tut erledigt die beschwerde
verfassungsbeschwerde des
beschwerdeführers zu grüne stritten
arabische erstens wird verworfen
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat den
beschwerdeführern mit ausnahme des
beschwerdeführers zu komisch drittens
arabisch erstens die notwendigen
auslagen für die verfassungsbeschwerden
zu erstatten
mit dem sie platz
meine damen und herren die
entscheidungen im vorliegenden verfahren
es wird niemanden in diesem raum
überraschen ist uns nicht leicht
gefallen
anlass sind sechs verfassungsbeschwerden
die sich unmittelbar gegen paragraph 217
des strafgesetzbuches pflichten der die
geschäftsmäßige förderung der
selbsttötung unter strafe stellt
beschwerdeführer sind unter anderem
vereine mit sitz in deutschland und in
der schweiz die suizidhilfe anbieten
schwer erkrankte person die ihr leben
mit hilfe eines solchen vereins beenden
wollen
und die teilweise bereits gestorben sind
sowie in der ambulanten oder stationären
patientenversorgung versorgung tätige
ärzte wie bereits eingangs der
mündlichen verhandlung im april letzten
jahres hervorgehoben habe stellt die
suizidhilfe ein hoch emotionales und
seit der antike kontrovers behandeltes
thema dar das mit den besten sinne
existenziellen grundfragen des
menschlichen daseins verknüpftes ist
rührt an die grundfesten unserer
ethischen moralischen und religiösen
überzeugungen über diese überzeugung war
hier in diesem verfahren nicht zu
befinden
aufgabe des senats war es ausschließlich
die verfassungsmäßigkeit der
einschlägigen strafrechts norden am
maßstab der freiheits gewährleistung des
grundgesetzes zu verurteilen dabei sind
wir zu folgenden wesentlichen
ergebnissen genannt erstens das
allgemeine persönlichkeitsrecht und fast
als ausdruck persönliche autonomie ein
recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben
dieses recht schließt die freiheit ein
sich das leben zu nehmen hierfür bei
dritten hilfe zu suchen und soweit sie
angeboten wird in anspruch zu nehmen
das recht auf selbstbestimmte sterben
ist nicht auf fremd definierte situation
wie schwere oder unheilbare krankheit
zustände oder bestimmte lebens und
krankheitsphasen beschränkt es besteht
in jeder phase menschlicher existenz
eine einengung des schutzbereichs auch
bestimmte ursachen und motive liefe auf
eine bewertung der beweggründe des zur
selbsttötung entschlossenen und auf eine
inhaltliche vorbestimmung hinaus die dem
freiheitsgedanken des grundgesetzes
fremdes die entscheidung des einzelnen
dem eigenen leben entsprechend seinem
verständnis von lebensqualität und
sinnhaftigkeit der eigenen existenz ein
ende zu setzen entzieht sich einer
bewertung anhand allgemeiner
wertvorstellung religiöser gebote
gesellschaftlicher leitbilder für den
umgang mit leben und tod und überlegung
objektiver vernünftigkeit sie bedarf
keiner weiteren begründung und
rechtfertigung sondern ist im
ausgangspunkt als autonome
selbstbestimmung von staat und
gesellschaft zu respektieren zweitens §
17 217 stgb greift in das allgemeine
persönlichkeitsrecht sterbewillige 1
auch wenn diese nicht unmittelbare
adressaten der norm das strafbewehrte
verbot der geschäftsmäßigen förderung
der selbsttötung entfaltet eine objektiv
die freiheit zum suizid einschränkende
wirkung
es macht es dem einzelnen faktisch
weitgehend unmöglich suizidhilfe zu
erhalten angesichts der existenziellen
bedeutung die der selbstbestimmung über
das eigene leben für die personale
identität individualität und integrität
zukommt wiegt der eingriff besonders
schwer
drittens der eingriff ist nicht
gerechtfertigt das verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen förderung der
selbsttötung ist am maßstab strikter
verhältnismäßigkeit zu messen diesen
genügt einen grundrechts ein strenges
gesetz nur wenn es legitime zwecke
verfolgt geeignet und erforderlich ist
diese zu erreichen und die von ihm
ausgehenden einschränkungen hierzu in
einem angemessenen verhältnis
wie von der vorschrift ausgehende
einschränkung des rechts auf
selbstbestimmte sterben ist jedenfalls
nicht angemessen
die anerkennung des rechts auf
selbstbestimmte sterben versagt dem
gesetzgeber zwar nicht allgemeine suizid
prävention zu betreiben und insbesondere
krankheitsbedingten selbsttötung
wünschen durch ausbau und stärkung
palliativmedizinischer
behandlungsangebote entgegenzuwirken
er kann und muss auch denjenigen
gefahren für die autonomie und das leben
entgegentreten die in den gegenwärtigen
und absehbaren realen
lebensverhältnissen begründet liegen und
eine entscheidung des einzelnen für die
selbsttötung und gegen das leben
beeinflussen können der insoweit auch
legitime einsatz des strafrechts zum
schutz der autonomen entscheidung des
einzelnen über die beendigung seines
lebens findet seinen renz aber dort wo
die freie entscheidung nicht mehr nur
geschützt sondern unmöglich gemacht wird
die straflosigkeit der selbsttötung und
der hilfe dazu steht als ausdruck der
verfassungsrechtlich gebotenen
anerkennung individuelle
selbstbestimmung nicht zur freien
disposition des gesetzgebers der
verfassungsordnung des grundgesetzes
liegt ein menschenbild zugrunde dass von
der würde des menschen und der freien
entfaltung der persönlichkeit in
selbstbestimmung und eigenverantwortung
bestimmt ist dieses menschenbild hat
ausgangspunkt jedes regulatorischen
ansatzes zu sein
die staatliche schutzpflicht zugunsten
der selbstbestimmung und des lebens kann
folgerichtig erst dort gegenüber dem
freiheitsrecht des einzelnen den vorrang
erhalten wo dieser einflüssen
ausgeliefert ist die die
selbstbestimmung über das eigene 7
gefährten diesen einflüssen darf und
muss die rechtsordnung durch vorsorge
und durch sicherungsinstrumente
entgegentreten
jenseits dessen ist die entscheidung des
einzelnen entsprechend seinem
verständnis von der sinnhaftigkeit der
eigenen existenz dem leben ein ende zu
setzen hingegen als abt autonummer
selbstbestimmung anzuerkennen diesen
verfassungsrechtlich zwingend zu wahren
denn entfaltungsraum autonummer
selbstbestimmung verletzt das verbot der
geschäftsmäßigen förderung der selbst
wird
es führt im gefüge mit der bei seiner
einführung vorgefundenen gesetzeslage
dazu dass das recht auf selbsttötung in
weiten teilen faktisch endwert ist die
regelung des paragraphen 217 stgb ist
zwar auf eine bestimmte die
geschäftsmäßige form der förderung der
selbsttötung beschränkt auch der damit
einhergehende verlust an autonomie ist
aber jedenfalls soweit und solange und
verhältnismäßig wie verbleibende option
nur eine theoretische nicht aber die
tatsächliche aussicht auf
selbstbestimmung mieten ohne
geschäftsmäßige angebote der suizidhilfe
ist ge einzelne maßgeblich auf die
individuelle bereitschaft eines arztes
angewiesen an einer selbsttötung
zumindest durch verschreibung der
benötigten wirkstoffe assistieren
mitzuwirken
von einer solchen individuellen
ärztlichen bereitschaft wird man bei
realistischer betrachtungsweise nur im
ausnahmefall ausgehen können erst wird
zeigen bislang eine geringe bereitschaft
suizidhilfe zu leisten und sind hierzu
auch nicht verpflichtet aus dem recht
auf selbstbestimmte sterben leidet sich
kein anspruch gegenüber dritten auf
suizidhilfe viertens paragraf 218 stgb
verletzt zudem grundrechte von personen
und vereinigungen die suizidhilfe
leisten möchten
der verfassungsrechtliche schutz des
durch paragraph 217 stgb unter strafe
gestellte handelns ergibt sich aus einer
funktionalen verschränkung der
grundrechte von suizidhilfe leistenden
personen und vereinigungen insbesondere
aus artikel 12 absatz 1 grundgesetz und
subsidiär artikel 2 absatz 1 grundgesetz
mit dem recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben
die entscheidung zur selbsttötung ist in
ihrer umsetzung nicht nur ein
tatsächlicher hinsicht davon abhängig
dass dritte breit sind gelegenheit zur
selbsttötung zu gewähren zu verschaffen
oder zu vermitteln
die dritte müssen ihre bereitschaft zur
suizidhilfe auch rechtlich umsetzen
dürfen der gewährleistung des rechts auf
selbsttötung korrespondiert daher auch
ein entsprechend weit reichender
grundrechtliche schutz des handelns von
suizid assistenten
5 § 200 17 std es wegen der
festgestellten verfassungsverstöße für
nichtig zu erklären eine einschränkende
verfasst
former auslegung ist nicht möglich weil
sie den absichten des gesetzgebers sowie
der lehre sechster
aus alldem meine damen und herren folgt
nicht dass der gesetzgeber die
suizidhilfe nicht regulieren eine solche
regelung muss sich aber an der
vorstellung vom menschen als einen
geistig sittlichen wesen aussichten das
darauf angelegt ist sich in freiheit
selbst zu bestimmen und selbst zu
entfalten
zum schutz der selbstbestimmung über das
eigene leben steht dem gesetzgeber in
bezug auf organisierte suizidhilfe ein
breites spektrum an möglichkeiten offen
sie reichen von procedural
sicherungsmechanismen etwa gesetzlich
festgeschriebener aufklärungs und warte
pflichten über erlaubnisvorbehalt die
die zuverlässigkeit von suizidhilfe
angeboten sichern bis zu verboten
besonders gefahr prächtige
erscheinungsform der suizidhilfe diese
können auch im strafrecht verankert oder
jedenfalls durch strafrechtlichen
sanktionierung von verstößen abgesichert
werden das recht auf selbsttötung
verbietet es aber die zulässigkeit einer
hilfe zur selbsttötung materiellen
kriterien zu unterwerfen sie etwa vom
vorliegen einer unheilbaren krankheit
abhängig zu machen
dagegen können je nach lebenssituation
unterschiedliche anforderungen an den
nachweis der ernsthaftigkeit und
dauerhaftigkeit eines selbst
tötungswillen gestellt werden allerdings
muss dem recht des einzelnen aufgrund
freier entscheidung mit unterstützung
dritter aus dem leben zu scheiden
auch faktisch hinreichender raum zur
entfaltung und umsetzung belassen werden
wir mögen seien in schuss bedauern wir
dürfen alles versuchen ihn umzustimmen
wir müssen seine freie entscheidung aber
in letzter konsequenz akzeptieren meine
damen und herren wie berichterstatterin
christa wolf und ich jetzt wie tragenden
gründe verlesen
ich verzichte darauf die zulässigkeit
hier noch einmal zu präsentieren und wir
werden gleich mit dem grünen teils teil
beginnen
das verfassungsbeschwerden sind so
welchem eine einleitung der der posten
des zweiten senats des
bundesverfassungsgerichts andreas
voßkuhle das urteil in
normalen setzen für sie für die
öffentlichkeit erläutert hat jetzt geht
es in die ausführliche verlesung des
gesamten urteils das kann noch mal gut
zwei stunden dauern und diese zeit
wollen wir nutzen um zu verstehen was
das bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
hat und welche konsequenzen dieses
urteil ganz praktisch hat sie haben es
gehört 2 § 217 strafgesetzbuch das
verbot menschen wiederholt beim suizid
zu helfen
verstößt gegen das grundgesetz die
richterinnen und richter haben
entschieden dass es ein im grundgesetz
verankertes recht auf selbstbestimmte
sterben geben muss und zwar unabhängig
davon ob jemand krank ist ohne oder
nicht unabhängig davon welche motive ihn
dazu veranlassen hilfe beim sterben in
anspruch zu nehmen
das heißt mit diesem urteil hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht die
rechtswirklichkeit in deutschland ab
sofort ab diesen minuten grundlegend
geändert professor taupitz erklären sie
uns was bedeutet dieses urteil ganz
konkret ganz praktisch für
sterbenskranke menschen wie herrn
feldmann
daher fällt mann hat recht behalten mit
seiner auffassung dass er ein recht
darauf hat selbst darüber zu entscheiden
auf welche art ersterben möchte auch
gegebenenfalls mit hilfe von anderen
wir haben jetzt wieder die rechtslage
wie sie vor 2015 bestand dass die
beihilfe zum suizid ist erlaubt sie ist
nicht strafbar
aber ganz wichtig ist ein suizid liegt
nur dann vor wenn der betroffene mensch
selbst verantwortlich selbstbestimmt
entscheidet also wenn jemand schwer
dement ist und damit nicht geistig fähig
ist dass die konsequenzen zu überschauen
dann begeht er keinen suizid sondern
wenn ihnen jemand anderer bei der tötung
hilft dann ist das eine fremd tötung sie
ist weiter strafbar
also nur ein selbstbestimmter mensch wie
herr feldmann der hat jetzt das recht
entsprechende mittel in anspruch zu
nehmen
herr feldmann erstmal glückwunsch das
ist ihr erfolg dass es ihr urteil
sagen sie beziehen
emotional sehr aufgewühlt aber ich bin
aber sehr erleichtert und das gibt mir
die sicherheit die ich brauche und das
leben der sich noch habe zu gestalten
und zu erleben mit meinen kindern mit
meiner familie ich möchte auch gerne
eine reale leben wenn der zeitpunkt
gekommen ist dass meine lebensqualität
mehr gegeben ist dann möchte ich gehe
und zwar selbst bestimmt und an dem tag
an dem ich es möchte und möchte dabei
dass meine tochter alleine beine ist
wenn ich dieses leben
ich habe keine angst vor dem sterben
aber ich habe angst vor 2 und dieses
urteil hat mir jetzt endlich endlich
nach so langer zeit die möglichkeit
gegeben das auch zu vollziehen und dafür
bin ich sehr dankbar
ja vier jahre haben sie dafür gekämpft
und das ist heute ihr erfolg glückwunsch
aus karlsruhe freut uns dass wir das
hier weiter mit ihm diskutieren können
und es betrifft ja nicht nur sie sondern
zwei prozent in etwa der sterbefälle
sind davon betroffen
das klingt nach gar nicht so viel aber
das und 20.000 menschen in deutschland
und am ende kann es jeden von uns
irgendwie treffen war goldmann gibt es
was sagen sie welche konsequenzen hat
das urteil ganz konkret für ihre arbeit
im hospiz
das ist eine absolute verstärkung der
notwendigkeit dass wir weiterhin das tun
was ich eben schon mal versucht habe
deutlich zu machen dass es absolut
oberste absolut oberstes gebot sein muss
menschen im sterben im sterbens weg zu
begleiten und das bestmögliche für sie
zu tun damit schmerzen nicht sein müssen
damit diese qualen von denen gefällt man
auch spricht nicht ängste auslösen
müssen und die begleitung dessen
gesichert ist das ist ein absoluter
appell oder eine verstärkung an all das
was wir palliativmedizinischen
pflegerisch tun können und müssen
und ich glaube da braucht es auch noch
etliches an ausbau in einen ebenen des
gesundheitssystems
in pflegeheimen einrichtungen
unterschiedlichster art und das zu
sichern und um sämtlichen menschen die
dem tod näher sind als dem leben
diesen des sterbens weg gut gestalten zu
können weil ich glaube und das ist eben
denke ich auch für deutlich geworden im
urteil dass herr voßkuhle vorgelesen hat
es muss immer darum gehen das leben bis
zum schluss zu sichern
das gute zu sichern und das ist das so
für die hospizarbeit auch ganz
wesentlich antritt und zwar für alle
insbesondere natürlich auch die
patientengruppe neben ansprachen demenz
patienten oder andere die eben auch
nicht mehr ganz selbstbestimmt
entscheiden könnten nur beim suizid
helfen ist mit dem tag heute wieder
möglich ganz konkret was gibt es da auch
für risiken also weil wir haben jetzt
eine rechtslage die wieder unreguliert
ist so wie sie vorher auch unreguliert
war aber was sehen sie da auch für
risiken vielleicht kommt man ja ist das
nicht ganz unreguliert und herr feldmann
muss jetzt erst mal jemanden finden der
ihnen das entsprechende mit dem moment
verschreibt zur verfügung stellt und da
steht noch das betäubungsmittelgesetz im
raum dass nach ganz überwiegender
auffassung von juristen dahin auszulegen
ist dass ein arzt entfällt man gerade
nicht zum zweck des suizids ein
entsprechendes betäubungsmittel
barbiturat und so weiter verschreiben
darf also der gesetzgeber ist jetzt
sicherlich aufgefordert auch im
politischen raum darüber zu diskutieren
auch in der gesellschaft muss darüber
diskutiert werden welche mittel denn
eine art bald 42 herrn feldmann oder
anderen suizidwilligen zur verfügung
stellen darf bisher ist der strick oder
andere ratschläge sich vor dem zug zu
werfen
aber die entsprechenden medikamente
dürfen nicht verschrieben werden wir
schauen auch nochmal anwalts bei den
begriffen oft durcheinander geht und
auch da haben wir mal eine grafik
vorbereitet um auch genau zu verstehen
worum es hier heute eigentlich geht
heute geht es nämlich ausschließlich um
die beihilfe zur selbsttötung also ganz
konkret um die frage ob ein arzt mehr
als einmal einem todkranken ein mittel
besorgen darf durch dass er stirbt und
genau das ist durch dieses urteil jetzt
erlaubt heute geht es dagegen nicht um
aktive sterbehilfe also nicht um die
frage beim arzt ein todbringendes
medikament auch verabreichen darf das
ist und bleibt in deutschland verboten
auch nach dem urteil heute und es geht
auch nicht um die passive sterbehilfe
also das beenden lebenserhaltender
maßnahmen das
war ist und bleibt in deutschland
erlaubt also es geht nur in
anführungsstrichen um die beihilfe zur
selbsttötung wieso aber ist genau das so
zentral
ja das ist so zentral also erstens finde
ich jetzt richtig dass in deutschland
die aktive tötung weiterhin verboten ist
auch die tötung auf verlangen also wenn
er fällt man zu seinem arzt sagen würde
bitte spritzen sie mir ein tödlich
wirkendes medikament dann macht sich der
papst nach geltendem recht strafbar
und ich finde das auch gut so denn es
ist wie die psychologen immer wieder
sagen ein sehr großer psychologischer
unterschied ob man dem arzt den armen
hält und sagt machen sie mal bringen sie
mich mal um oder ob man das tödlich
wirkende medikament selbst einnimmt
es gibt wohl eine erhebliche
hemmschwelle das tödlich wirkende
medikamente sich selbst einzuverleiben
und nur darum geht es bei der beihilfe
zum suizid dass der arzt dem
suizidwilligen das medikament zur
verfügung stellen darf also hinstellen
darf oder ihm vorschreiben darf und der
suizidwillige muss es dann aber selbst
nehmen
das würde sehr unterschiedlich
gehandhabt auch in europa wir helfen
sagen sie herr feldmann
ich bin ich bin in vielen dingen
parallel dieser meinung aber ich finde
dass der gesetzgeber jetzt geboten ist
dieses gesetz des betäubungsmittelgesetz
das btm gesetz entsprechend schnell zu
verändern damit das was jetzt im gesetz
von von dem bundesverfassungsgericht
erlaubt es auch durchgeführt werden kann
auch realisiert werden kann und das ist
doch sehr wichtig ein sehr guter onkel
da ist dann da ist wenn die politik
gefragt und da habe ich meine großen
bedenken
ich habe auch große bedenken was unseren
rechtsstaat betrifft ja genau das will
ich einmal das bundesverfassungs herr
feldmann ich auch nicht genau auch in
bayern gibt jetzt sehr zentral
genauso ist es ja also rechtlich ist
natürlich die politik nicht verpflichtet
jetzt zu handeln aber politisch
moralisch ethisch muss nicht jetzt auch
das betäubungsmittelgesetz geändert oder
zumindest anders verfassungskonform
angebaut
ja nach meiner auffassung jahr das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat ja vor
einiger zeit schon entschieden weil sich
die ärzteschaft weil die ärzteschaft
keine suizidbeihilfe ganz überwiegend
jedenfalls leistet und in einigen
berufsordnungen der landesärztekammern
sogar ein striktes verbot der beihilfe
zum suizid verankert ist deswegen muss
der staat in gestalt des bundes
bundesinstituts für arzneimittel und
medizinprodukte den sterbewilligen die
entsprechende medikamente zur verfügung
stellen
also es gibt schon ein
höchstrichterliches urteil das das
betäubungsmittelgesetz dahin auslegt
jawohl es ist erlaubt in bestimmten
fällen sowie zahlreiche für durch
verschreibung der entsprechenden
medikamente zu leisten aber das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat das 1 1 ein
schweres leiden geknüpft und das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht heute aber vom
tisch gewischt
genau dann nochmal 15 das ja auch
menschen wie herrn feldmann im wege
steht ist die berufsordnung der ärzte in
sehr vielen bundesländern ist es so dass
es stärke ärzten untersagt ist beihilfe
zum suizid zu leisten sie verlieren ihre
approbation muss müssen da die
berufsordnung geändert werden oder auch
verfassungskonformen ausgelegt weil
sonst faktisch findet man ja immer noch
keinen arzt also ich halte diese berufs
ordnungsvorschriften dienst in der tat
in zehn bundesländern gibt halte ich für
verfassungswidrig weil die ärzte kann
man nicht die legitimation haben eine so
wesentliche entscheidung mit auswirkung
auf ihre patienten tatsächlich in ihren
berufsordnung in den satzungen zu regeln
aber es steht noch in vielen
berufsordnungen drin und da ist die
ärzteschaft wirklich aufgefordert auch
politisch aufgefordert hier an eine
andere regelung zu treffen vor allem
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe wenn
nicht mehr ärzte dazu in die lage
versetzt werden todbringende medikamente
zu verschreiben und zur verfügung zu
stellen
dann bleibt doch bei den stern gliese
verein die können noch mit dem tag heute
auch wieder ihre arbeit aufnehmen möchte
ich es gibt kein hindernis das der
verein sterbe hilfe deutschland in
hamburg der jahr zu den klägern gehörte
wie wir gehört haben dass er seine
arbeit ab heute wieder aufnimmt
das heißt ihre politische forderung wäre
dass die das direkt jetzt auch gehandelt
werden muss ja ich meine dass
der gesetzgeber wollte er damals gerade
diesen sterbehilfe vereinen die das
organisiert die das auch bewerben
gegebenenfalls dass ihnen das handwerk
gelegt wird
ich hatte hielt er ist für viel besser
wenn das in der hand der ärzteschaft
wäre denn die ärzte werden durch strenge
ist berufsrecht reglementiert die werden
überwacht durch die ärztekammer sie sind
nicht gewinnorientiert und vor allem
sind sie dem leben verpflichtet und sie
sollten den suizidwilligen
lebensbejahende alternativen anbieten
zuerst hat herr voßkuhle ja auch gesagt
wir dürfen versuchen die menschen zu
überzeugen dass sie von ihrem wunsch
ablassen
aber wenn sie es dann immer noch wollen
dann müssen wir das respektieren vielen
dank ihnen ein hier heute die sie mit
uns diskutiert haben auf der wir
diskutieren gleich weiter
die bilder im kopf behalten
daher setzen wir gleich an ich danke der
runde und ich danke ihnen liebe
zuschauern ein zuschauer das war nämlich
schon unser zdf spezial live vom
bundesverfassungsgericht zum urteil der
sterbehilfe wir sagen tschüss aber nur
im zdf-hauptprogramm denn es geht direkt
weiter auf der heute de auf zdf facebook
und dem youtube kanal und da stehen dann
ihre fragen ihre meinung im mittelpunkt
und sie haben viele fragen und viele
meinung und haben nämlich schon vorab
sehr sehr viele e mails erreicht sehr
ausführliche sehr kluge fragen und die
werde ich hier weiter an die runde geben
sie können sich jederzeit melden
mitdiskutieren und es lohnt sich auch
ein blick in die zdf mediathek dort
haben nämlich die kollegen von wiso
alles wissenswerte zur vorsorge am
lebensende zusammengetragen unter
anderem finden sie dort wieso tipps zum
thema vorsorgevollmacht
patientenverfügung und testament in
vielen dank und bis gleich hoffentlich
facebook youtube heute die ich freue
mich auf den austausch dienen
[Musik]
senden aber direkt auf der heute de und
deshalb würde ich auch direkt dort
wieder anfang juni beendet haben herr
feldmann sagen sie ihren einwand ja das
ist ja so dass die ärzte kann man das
war den ärzten verbieten aber das ist
nicht rechtlich gesichert ja das haben
das steht nicht im gesetz das die insel
ist sondern das ist eine maßnahme die
ärztekammern für sich entschieden haben
und das entspricht nicht also nach
meiner auffassung nicht hier den rahmen
der legalität
nachdem jetzt bundesverfassungsgericht
dieses urteil so gefällt hat was sagen
sie dazu ja herr feldmann die ärzte kann
man haben das gute recht für ihre
eigenen mitglieder nämlich die ärzte
besondere pflichten einschränkende
pflichten festzulegen zum beispiel zur
kollegialität zuerwerb zulässigen
werbung zum notfalldienst und vielen
anderen gebieten auch wir sind beide
sind aber sehr wohl über stimmen überein
dass wir zweifel haben ob dieses verbot
der beihilfe zum suizid dass die ärzte
kann man in manchen bundesländern
verankert haben in ihren berufsordnung
ob das verfassungskonform ist aber
grundsätzlich haben ärzte kann man sehr
wohl das recht ihren mitgliedern
strengere pflichten aufzuerlegen als
andere bürger sie haben wir haben vorab
schon sie aufgerufen gehabt uns ihre
fragen zu schicken und einer unserer
user hat sich direkt mit einer video
botschaft an uns gewandt wir uns jetzt
anhören wollen und dann in der runde
diskutieren gutes recht als mensch und
bürger mein leben zu beenden
wann immer ich jetzt will es ist absolut
indiskutabel dass unser staat dieses
selbstbestimmungsrecht nicht
akzeptiert was sagen sie dazu frau
wollte man wird das da hör mir noch mal
der staat sollte sich da nicht
einmischen
ja wir haben ja eben gehört dass das
gesetz was wir bislang hatten von 215
bis heute gekippt worden ist ich möchte
darauf nochmal antworten den blick auf
die frage die sie eben eingangs stellten
was so zentral an diesem ganzen gedanken
ist und mir kommt dann noch eine
dimension wesentlich zu kurz das ist
nämlich letztlich der autonomie begriff
der immer wieder umkreist wird aber den
ich für ganz zentral halte und der für
meine begriffe häufig landläufig auch
etwas verkürzt übersetzt wird weil ich
es tatsächlich für gefährlich erachtet
wenn wir autonomie letztlich so mit
dieser konnotation von autarkie
übersetzen dann geht es um tatsächlich
völlige unabhängigkeit und ich bestimme
nur für mich und da wird eine dimension
für meine begriffe deutlich zu kurz
gesehen die die dimension der autonomie
aber mit mainz das ist nämlich die man
sagte die relationale verfasstheit des
menschen das heißt letztlich so viel wie
der gedanke ich darf dich brauchen dich
mensch dich nächsten darf ich brauchen
damit ich das mit mir besser geht und
das übersetzt in den kontext von hilfe
beim sterben meint nichts die die pille
meint nicht den letzten zeitpunkt
vielleicht irgendwann auch ja aber im
moment und das was noch viel zu kurz
kommt ist der weg bis dahin und ich
möchte da eine dimension die
gesellschaft sich somit und mit sich
entwickelt bedienen da geht es da
tatsächlich um die sorge struktur wenn
wir in deutschland heute sagen müssen
feststellen müssen dass patienten sagen
ich möchte meiner familie nicht zur last
fallen ich möchte angehörigen nicht zur
last fallen ich möchte nicht beschweren
nicht sein für andere dann ist das
vielleicht einerseits verständlich und
andererseits doch auch für meine
begriffe eine bankrotterklärung an
unsere solidarische gesellschaft die
beansprucht eigentlich für den anderen
da zu sein und ich finde da müssen wir
viel stärker ansetzen um den menschen in
einer autonomen die eben auch die
morgens wird das übersehe sagen sie so
wollte man da etwas übersehen es gibt
eine studie seit vier jahren
anerkannt ist die von fachleuten und
spezialisten erstellt worden ist und die
besagt entgegen dem was auch als
argument genommen wird dass dann mehr
menschen sich das leben nehmen würden
denn ist dem entspricht aber nicht der
realität
man hat festgestellt dass in dem
zeitraum und dieses gesetz bestand hatte
bis heute das eben nicht der fall war
sondern dass sich in etwa gleich
gehalten ist stabil geblieben ist ja und
das muss man auf einmal so sehen also
die jetzt argument das immer genutzt
worden ist auch von ärzten und
ärztekammern
es spricht nicht der realität aber herr
feldmann frau bergmann hat doch recht
das in aller erster linie mal die
palliativmedizin ausgebaut werden müssen
muss dass die rahmenbedingungen so sind
so sehr müssen dass niemand aus
finanziellen gründen sich den tod
wünschen muss also die
gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse müssen
gut sein und wenn dann immer noch jemand
den suizid bund hat dann soll er
selbstverständlich diesen wunsch auch
verwirklichen können
aber er soll nicht dahin getrieben
werden durch umwelteinflüsse sage ich
mal durch gesellschaftliche einflüsse
durch gesellschaftlichen druck da stimme
ich mit ihnen frau woltmann völlig waren
ja und ich kann das tatsächlich sie
sagen jetzt ist entspricht nicht der
realität fällt mir nicht kann es aus
westlicher perspektive vielleicht ein
bisschen korrigieren wir erleben ist
immer wieder in den üblichen
einrichtungen ob nun ambulant oder
stationär das natürlich auch bei uns
menschen sind es die sagen ich möchte so
nicht mehr leben ich kann so nicht mehr
aber wenn man separat und benutzte das
wort der hörenden medizin das nicht ein
sehr sympathischen begriff also es geht
letztlich darum die begleitung des
menschen so ernst zu nehmen damit ich
dass ich hingehöre um was geht es denn
eigentlich und wir machen tatsächlich
aus plötzlich immer wieder die erfahrung
dass menschen die mit diesem wunsch an
uns herantreten
das gespräch suchen und das ist schon
mal großartig wenn wir dann auf dieses
gespräch reagieren mit diesen menschen
eruieren worum geht es eigentlich ändert
sich häufig die frage richtung stellen
wir fest dass sie sagen eigentlich würde
ich gerne noch mal den sohn mit dem ich
seit fünf jahren nicht mehr gesprochen
habe und im streit liegen treffen
das heißt als beispiel genannt das sind
biografische sorgen die dahinter liegen
die eine auflösung suchen
und ganz oft eigentlich immer wieder
stellen wir fest wenn wir das gespräch
zu ende führen steht am ende des
gesprächs ist nicht mehr der der das
thema des anfangs nämlich die beide zum
suizid sondern erstmal ganz andere
themen stehen im vordergrund die sie
gelöst wissen wollen
das meint sorge um den anderen in
kultivierter weise wie wir schließlich
schon leisten und wie ich glaube dass
die politisch dazu verpflichtet sind
insgesamt gewährt das nicht unbedingt
auszubauen und deswegen sollte doch die
ärzteschaft auch das angebot
unterbreiten ihr könnt offen mit uns
sprechen wir haben gegebenenfalls auch
lebensbejahender alternativen
wir sorgen dafür dass die
rahmenbedingungen gut sind aber wenn
sich die betroffenen nicht trauen an ein
nahes heranzutreten überhaupt diesen
wunsch zu äußern
dann kommt es zu dem gespräch das recht
genannt vielleicht auch soja eine
zuschauerin hatte uns vor abgeschrieben
das tabu für das töten darf nicht
gebrochen werden hatte sie geschrieben
vor der entscheidung wir sind ohne
unseren willen in diese welt geboren
worden und möchten nicht mit dem willen
anderer oder des eigenen wieder gehen
dürfen es gibt medikamente
sterbebegleitung hospize du sollst nicht
töten steht im fünften gebot der
christlichen kirche da schreibt
entwickeln das ist jetzt dieser
christliche gedanke ist dass auch ihr
ansatz zu sagen im grunde
wir haben also der der mensch darf das
leben nicht nehmen er hat auch nicht
gegeben sondern ist einfach in gottes
hand ja also ja es ist insbesondere wenn
wir da haben wir eben auch schon mal
kurz besprochen wenn wir quasi ärzten
legitimieren du darfst töten dann ist
dann ist etwas schief weil es eben
selbst angesprochen er zu sind zum
schutz des lebens angetreten zur heilung
des lebens und zur begleitung dessen
auch dann wenn es schwierig ist und wenn
das christliche bedient wird dann ist
zutiefst christo logische botschaft dass
die menschen gerade da wo sie in ihrer
fragilität stehen in ihrer
zerbrechlichkeit an verletzt hatten
zunächst und vor allem begleiten indem
was dran ist und dass mit ihnen
gemeinsam aufsuchen heraushören
gemeinsam besprechen diskutieren und
lösungswege suchen noch mal als mensch
ganz am ende
das hat herr voßkuhle eben auch gesagt
ist keiner von uns dazu berechtigt den
anderen zu verurteilen wenn er seinen
weg welt das ist sicherlich so
aber auf christlicher perspektive und
hospiz sichert sich glaube ich ist es
lange noch ganz viel zu tun und haben
jetzt noch mal live von ihnen auch
nachrichten sehr viele nachrichten
erreicht so viel hat man schreibt auf
facebook an und könnten sie bitte herrn
feldmann den dank vieler zuhörer
übermitteln herr fällt mich auf das
kommt an eine zuschauerin hat schon
geschrieben dass sehr viele zuschauer
dankbar sind dass sie das urteil hier
stritten haben und heute mit uns
diskutieren und stefan thiel auf
facebook gefragt ich frage mich welcher
art das macht die haben einen eid auf
leben abgelegt und das ist ja genau das
problem professor toppits was sie
angesprochen haben also jetzt ganz
praktisch er fällt man hat wieder das
recht beihilfe zum suizid legal zu
bekommen
aber von wem das muss eine
gewissensentscheidung des jeweiligen
arzt zu sein
herr feldmann und niemand hat einen
anspruch hat einen rechtsanspruch gegen
einen arzt beihilfe zum suizid zu
leisten also das ist die
eigenverantwortliche entscheidung und
feldmann und es ist die
eigenverantwortliche entscheidung des
arztes der helfen möchte
und wenn jemand aus christlichen motiven
heraus so eine hilfe nicht in anspruch
nehmen möchte oder sie nicht leisten
möchte ist dass das gute recht von
diesen beiden menschen das ärztliche
berufsrecht verbietet es in manchen
bundesländern in manchen ärztekammer ob
das rechtswirksam ist darüber kann man
lange streiten ich halte die
vorschriften für rechtsunwirksam aber
die ärzteschaft muss sich jetzt
positionieren also es sollte auch im
politischen raum sicherlich jetzt nicht
einfach so bleiben wie es ist sondern
der gesetzgeber und auch die ärzteschaft
sollten sich überlegen welche
vernünftigen regelungen wartezeiten vier
augen prinzip dass zwei ärzte die
eigenverantwortlichkeit als betreuer
helfen
er wählt man sein sie dadurch etwas zu
sagen
es wird ja auch diesbezüglich wenn es so
kommen sollte
es ist ja so wird der bundestag gefragt
werden
dort werden dann entscheidungen
getroffen was das btm gesetz bezirks das
betäubungsmittelgesetz und da bin ich
mir ziemlich da bin ich mir ziemlich
sicher
sie haben im bundestag drei große
lobbyisten die die politik weitgehend
mitbestimmen
das ist einmal die pharmazeutik dass die
katholische kirche und die evangelische
kirche denkt jetzt überhaupt nichts und
du hast das schlüsseljahr ist verbaut
man darf ich ihnen sagen dass ich
evangelisch bin auch evangelisch bleibe
weil die evangelische kirche auch eine
gesellschaftliche positive aufgabe
übernimmt aber nicht in der
glaubensfrage ich gehe ich in die kirche
weil zum beispiel immer noch latent wie
gesagt latent versteckt über teufel und
jetzt darfst du nicht jedes darf du und
das darf und das musst du geregelt wird
das ist eine sache indem ihr aber
überhaupt nicht gefällt das sind auch
die auftritte der aus den kirchen damit
begründet zum teil und ich muss ihnen
sagen ich bin sehr gläubig ich bete
jeden tag weil ich es gibt ein ein
höheres wesen was ich nicht bezeichnen
kann eine höhere macht das mag energie
seien wir sagen gott dazu aber eines ist
sicher für mich wenn es einen gott gibt
dann gibt es nur einen gnädigen und
einen gütigen gott und keinen strafenden
gott wird latent vor der kirche oftmals
immer wieder gepredigt wird herr
feldmann das stimme ihn viele zuschauer
zu wir haben auch nachrichten bekommen
bianca auf facebook schreibt bravo hat
lange genug gedauert bin gespannt auf
die umsetzung und roselinde helm und
schreibt auf facebook also die perfekte
lösung ist es nicht erst wenn die
hindernisse aus dem weg geräumt sind und
wie immer bei auf youtube schreibt sehr
gutes urteil recht auf selbstbestimmung
aber immer wieder der hinweis auf die
hindernisse die sehen sie auch
hauptorten noch es ist noch geltendes
recht was im betäubungsmittelgesetz
steht es ist noch geltend was in den
berufsordnungen steht oder jedenfalls
die die weigerung von vielen ärzten aus
sorge vor berufsrechtlichen sanktionen
dass sie keine entsprechende hilfe zur
verfügung stellen und dass das deshalb
auch dazu führt dass nicht die
vertrauensvollen gesprächen mit den
ärzten geführt werden das ist mein
hauptpunkt wenn ihr natürlich sollen
nicht die ärzteschaft pauschal sagen wir
sind jetzt die sterbehelfer und es soll
insbesondere auch keine werbung in der
öffentlichkeit geben also auf der ersten
seite einer zeitung kommen sie zu uns
wenn sie leben
würde sind wir helfen ihnen effektiv und
preiswert das soll natürlich nicht sein
also wir sind beide völlig einer meinung
und das war ja auch der anlass
vielleicht lizenzgeber darf nicht
normalität werden darf nicht ein
normales angebot in unserem
gesundheitssystem geben wenn sie nicht
mehr wollen dann helfen wir ihnen zum
stern das ist ja auch das wozu das
verfassungsgericht aufgerufen hat zu
einem verantwortungsvollen umgang mit
dieser neu gewonnenen zurückgewonnenen
feiert die verfassung wir haben zwar
keinen auftrag an den gesetzgeber
formuliert aber nicht gesagt bis dann im
dann muss es ein neues gesetz geben aber
sie haben ja schon sehr deutlich gemacht
das ist eigentlich regelung geben müsste
also es ist schon ein aufruf an den
gesetzgeber sich dieser thematik
anzunehmen
haben sie haben insbesondere auch
angedeutet jedenfalls dass auch die
faktische und möglichkeit für betroffene
die suizidwillige entsprechende
medikamente zu bekommen die faktische
unmöglichkeit dass das schon ein
grundrechtseingriff ist also auch das
geltende betäubungsmittelgesetz in
seiner derzeitigen form ist ein
faktisches hindernis für betroffene und
dieses faktische hindernis meine ich
muss der gesetzgeber angesehen wollen
wenn ich die gerichte die entsprechenden
vorschriften anders interpretieren sowie
das man sagen berichtete ein einen
ersten schritt gemacht hat ja herr
feldmann auch die gerichte können das
betäubungsmittelgesetz anders
interpretieren also in der vergangenheit
der fall war und auch einmal das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat auch schon
einen ganz wichtigen schritt aus meiner
sicht in die richtige richtung richtig
ich möchte meine ganzen also in das will
ja auch schon eine gesetzgebung gibt
wird auch seit 2.15 nämlich das hospiz
und palliativ gesetzt was damals ja auch
mit eingeführt worden ist und auch da
ist noch ganz viel spielraum in der
umsetzung dessen was
palliativmedizinischen palliativ care
und in der sonstigen haus südlichen
landschaft möglich ist also ich gebe als
beispiel dass es in verschiedenen
pflegeeinrichtungen bundesweit momentan
die frage unterwegs ist wie können wir
hospizliche kultur wie können wir das
hat die tatsächliche auseinandersetzung
zu diesem thema stärker fördern
da sind wir noch in den kinderschuhen
und ich glaube da ist das größtes gebot
dafür das kultivieren und zwar
tatsächlich als auseinandersetzung in
den einrichtungen der mitarbeiter von
von a bis z und auch in den
dazugehörigen angehörigen die dann ja
die patienten auch in den häusern haben
dass wir dafür eintreten was es heißt
sich damit auseinander zu
gut das lebensende zu gestalten denn
auch sterbende sind lebende bis zum
schluss kam noch eine frage über
facebook die geht ein sehr profitables
michael pieck hövel fragt was ist wenn
er tot ist ein symptom einer erkrankung
ist zum beispiel depressionen
ja der suizid ist juristisch so
definiert es ist der freiverantwortlich
der selbstbestimmten tod deswegen
spricht man ja auch vom freitod
aber man weiß dass sehr viele menschen
die einen suizidversuch unternehmen dass
sie diesen suizidversuch gar nicht mit
der letzten konsequenz wollen nämlich
dass der tod eintritt sondern ist
oftmals ein hilferuf an die an die
umwelt ich habe ein problem helft mir
und in einer solchen situation darf
natürlich dem suizid wunsch nicht
rechnung getragen werden oder wenn der
suizid wunsch durch krankheit verzerrt
ist durch demenz und so weiter
dann darf der suizid wunsch und es ist
dann eigentlich keinen suizid wunsch im
strengen juristen sind dann darf dieser
sterbe diesen sterbewunsch nicht
rechnung getragen werden nicht
nachgeholfen werden
also insofern muss frei verantwortlich
sein der betreffende damit jemand ihm
dabei helfen direkt daran knüpft die
frage von stephan rehm auch über
facebook an
wie lange dürfen die ärzte versuchen
einem auszureden suizid zu begehen hilft
mir ja nichts wenn die sich dem zehn
jahre dann zehn jahre dafür zeit nehmen
ja da gibt es natürlich keine festen
regeln das hängt natürlich davon ab von
der jeweiligen situation wie im ersten
mal will ich eigentlich hier noch mal
andersrum anfangen ich betone noch
einmal es ist eine eigene
gewissensentscheidung des arztes kein
arzt ist verpflichtet dem sterbewunsch
nachzukommen ja also wenn eine art sagt
mich persönlich überzeugen ihre
argumente nicht mich persönlich
überzeugt das nicht dass sie aus diesem
grund aus dem leben scheiden und
deswegen helfe ich ihnen nicht ist das
ein sein bundesrecht des arztes
aber wenn ein arzt der auffassung ist
jawohl ich kann das akzeptieren der
mensch hat schweres leiden der mensch
hat so großen kummer aus welchen gründen
auch immer dass ich es respektiere und
akzeptiere dass er aus dem leben
scheiden will dann darf er ihm helfen
ebenfalls eine frage die uns immer über
youtube erreicht hat auch sehr konkret
werde finanziert denn die sterbehilfe
wer trägt die kosten dafür ja auch das
ist natürlich ungeklärt
wenn ein arzt tätig wird dann bekommt er
dafür ein gewisses honorar nach der
gebührenordnung und dieses grund honorar
sage ich mal wird er sicherlich auch für
diese tätigkeit bekommen die medikamente
müssen bezahlt werden
irgendwann muss der gesetzgeber auch
dazu eine lösung finden im ärztlichen
gebührenrecht und in der in der frage
wie die medikamente zur verfügung
gestellt werden das war das was ich eben
eingangs meinte dann wird es das schief
und verzerrt weil dann scheinbar die die
beihilfe zum suizid wie ein
therapieangebot werden könnte mutmaßen
könnte und das halte ich tatsächlich für
hochgradig gefährlich na ja gut aber man
kann natürlich die gebühren tatbestände
wie ärztliche beratung nahmen dann kann
man natürlich lassen fall anwenden und
rezept ausstellen da muss ja auch da
steht ja auch in der gebührenordnung
nicht drin rezept für das oder rezept
winners sondern das ist dann eben die
gebühr für das hatte ja was wird dann
schief wenn man weiß welche medikamente
die berater und aufgeschrieben wird also
ja es ist falsch nämlich nach wie vor
und wir schauen uns noch mal an dann ist
das ja auch so einen blick über in die
nachbarländer
wir haben auch da eine grafik
vorbereitet die zeigt wie es die
europäischen nachbarn machen und auf der
grafik können sie sehen in den benelux
ländern ist die aktive sterbehilfe
erlaubt denn sterbenskranke menschen das
wünschen dürfen ärzte ihnen dort ein
tödliches medikament verabreichen
in der schweiz ist die beihilfe zur
selbsttötung straffrei das gilt auch für
organisierte sterbehelfer sowie seit
heute in deutschland dänemark österreich
an frankreich haben ähnliche regelungen
die bislang in deutschland hier ist
passive sterbehilfe möglich also dass
beenden der künstlichen ernährung auf
wunsch und dann haben wir noch das
katholische polen da können sie es sich
schon vorstellen verbietet sterbehilfe
grundsätzlich das so ansehen sind wir
mit dem tag heute beim modell schweiz
wir sind mit dem modell heute in
gewisser weise beim modell schweiz wir
sind aber noch liberaler wenn man diesen
ausdruck hier in diesem zusammenhang
überhaupt verwenden will
denn in der schweiz ist die sogenannte
gewinn süchtige sterbehilfe untersagt
also wenn jemand aus profitstreben
profitstreben also aus finanziellen
erwägungen die beihilfe zum suizid
leistet ist das in der schweiz verboten
nur diese regelung haben wir in
deutschland eben ab heute nicht weil die
gewinnerzielung die wiederholungs
absicht alles da spielt heute keine
rolle mehr
müsste das direkt geändert und angepasst
werden herr feldmann ich sagen sie wird
noch seiten nein nein ich habe da ich
hatte wieder eine andere meinung also
ich kann nur über meine persönlichen
erfahrungen reden meine persönliche
erfahrung mit der deutschen sterbehilfe
ist eine sehr positive und eine
erfahrung die auch das leben
ausgerichtet war nicht auf das sterben
ja und ich habe oft mit leuten vom
seiner leute sterbehilfe gesprochen und
die haben immer wieder das fand ich auch
für mich sehr spannend fand ich sehr
positiv weil das meine denkweise um eine
denkrichtung untermauert das leben hat
vor lang in ihrer beziehung aber wenn
dann der sachverhalt eintritt dass meine
krankheit egal in welcher art und weise
soweit fortschreitet bei mir ist es so
dass ich keine angst vorm sterben habe
dass er angst habe zum ersticken was ich
bei meiner schwester erlebt habe die
gleiche erkrankung hatte und genau das
ist der punkt wo ich sagen meine
lebensqualität die ja in die welt
individuell unterschiedlich gesetzt wird
die ich mir gesetzt habe wenn die nicht
mehr gegeben ist dann möchte ich gehen
und das ist eben genau der punkt es ist
jetzt erlaubt und ich werde natürlich
wenn da wenn es so weit sein sollte
ich hoffe dass ich noch länger jahre
lebe und meinen verwandten vor allem in
meiner tochter manuela erleben darf da
wäre ich dankbar für aber wenn der
zeitpunkt kommen sollte wäre ich jetzt
die sterbehilfe in anspruch nehmen und
das darf ich jetzt und darüber sagt dass
das beruhigt mich sehr und das gibt mir
auch meine gelassenheit die für hatte
wieder weil sich in den letzten vier
jahren das war ein
auch unter schlaflosigkeit gelitten habe
weil eben diese differenzen vorhanden
waren und weil eben auch wie gesagt die
politik kirchen und so weiter und ich
muss ihnen sagen für goldmann die
palliativmediziner haben hier auch
geklagt gegen die sind § 217 stgb ja und
das haben sie das haben sie nicht
erwähnt ja und das haben wir viele ärzte
geklagt gegen dieses gesetz das wohl
auch nicht erwähnt das wurde mir gesagt
schon ein paar ärzten
ja es haben ja auch viele andere
verbände humanistische verband
deutschland das heißt schon was hat ja
auch gegen dieses gesetz geklagt und
viele andere mehr
und das sollte man und das sollte man
mal in relation setzen zu den anderen
dingen und dann muss man zu dem
entschluss kommen zu dem resultat dass
darf was heute der professor dr
was früher verkündet hat genau das ist
was gut und richtig ist
so sieht es aus und so sieht es auch
eher feldmann und genau dazu haben wir
die nachfrage vor einer userin sigrid
ley sie auf facebook schreibt also wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe ist es
nicht strafbar wenn ich noch selber bei
vollem verstand bis nach ärztlicher
sicht aber so krank bin dass ich auf
jeden fall sterben werde
ich muss also auf jeden fall bei klarem
verstand sein und darf keine hilfe in
anspruch nehmen der tauplitz wenn ich es
richtig verstanden habe ist es gerade so
dass man nicht sterbenskrank nicht kann
sondern aus welchem grund auch immer
nicht unter depressionen oder
drogeneinfluss oder nicht mehr zu reden
war oder demand also bei klarem verstand
aber mich bei klarem verstand sage ich
möchte sterben und ein arzt finde der
mir glaubt dass versteht nachvollziehen
kann und bereit ist mir zu helfen dann
kann ich suizidbeihilfe nan genau wir
haben eine ähnliche politische
diskussion schon damals als ich als die
patientenverfügung geregelt wurde im
gesetz
da gab es auch eine diskussion dass
viele gesagt haben auch viele
parlamentarier gesagt haben mit hilfe
einer patientenverfügung also einer
voraus verfügung in die zukunft
kann ich nur lebenserhaltende maßnahmen
ablehnen für eine situation in der ich
schon kurz vom tod bin und das hat der
gesetzgeber aber aus guten gründen
abgelehnt und hat ins gesetz
ausdrücklich hinein geschrieben
eine patientenverfügung entfaltet
wirkung unabhängig von dem
krankheitszustand und unabhängig davon
ob das lebensende
da ist also ich kann eine
lebenserhaltende maßnahme verweigern
ablehnen
und genau so ist es jetzt auf dieser
linie auch vom bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt worden es gibt kein recht des
staates eine motivation zu überprüfen
eine motivation suche vorzunehmen und zu
kontrollieren ob das überzeugende gründe
sind die der betroffene haben oder nicht
übertragen
genau dazu auch die frage seine marx auf
facebook hatte ich richtig verstanden
das ist nun auch legitim ist suizid zu
begehen wenn man nicht schwer krank ist
ja so ist es dann bedeutet das doch das
hospiz nicht beteiligt wären müssen sie
nicht müssen sie nicht nein wenn ich als
als frei verantwortlicher mensch
entscheidet beispielsweise bin ich
motorradfahrer wäre und wenn ich mich
entscheiden würde
ich möchte nicht querschnittsgelähmt
nach einem motorradunfall weiterleben
dann möchte ich lieber sterben
ich habe das gute recht in einer
patientenverfügung das oder aktuell zu
sagen bitte keine lebenserhaltenden
maßnahmen und genauso habe ich in dieser
situation auch jetzt wieder das recht
einen hut zu bitten dass er mir ein
tödlich wirkendes medikament zur
verfügung stelle direkt daran knüpft
auch die frage von nadja du mal sehr
pfeiler auf facebook an
denn motorradunfall was ist jetzt wenn
ich zum beispiel querschnittsgelähmt bin
und wenn niemand mehr aktiv helfen darf
also die frage ist was ist wenn ich also
weil aktive sterbehilfe bleibt verboten
darum ging es ja heute nicht was ist
wenn ich das medikament gar nicht mehr
selber schlucken kann ja also wenn
jemand bis zum hals hier gelebt ist dann
gibt es ja immerhin noch apparaturen die
einem das trinken ermöglichen also wenn
man ihm zb einen becher mit dem tödlich
wirkendes medikament mit einem strohhalm
entstellt dann kann er ja mit seinem
mund die flüssigkeit ansaugen und kann
sich so zum in den tod bringen
wenn jemand aber gar keine reaktion mehr
zeigen kann also eine apparatur wieder
mit dem mund bewegen kann noch mit den
augen gegebenenfalls auch solche
reparaturen gibt es ja dann kann man
auch wahrscheinlich nicht von selbst
bestimmt ausgehen
und dann wäre in der tat die beihilfe
nicht erlaubt
aber das sind ja so seltene fälle und
wie gesagt die abzusagen auch da gibt es
dann eben technische möglichkeiten wo
man in denen man mit gelähmten
beispielsweise ist dass die frei die
auch nochmal ankunft von anke paul auf
facebook was ist mit menschen die an
keiner geistigen einschränkungen leiten
also selbst bestimmt aber körperlich
nicht mehr in der lage dazu sind das
glas mit dem tödlichen medikament zum
mund zu führen oder nicht mehr ab
schlucken können also künstlich ernährt
werden ja also das verabreichen ist nach
geltendem recht strafbar verabreichen
eines tödlich wirkenden medikament aber
gibt es die juristen sagen wenn man
nicht mehr schlucken kann
das ist eine technische frage die ärzte
bangen worden müssen ich kann mir eine
solche situation eigentlich nicht
vorstellen denn gewisse also schlug
bewegungen die wird ein mensch der noch
selbstbestimmt entscheiden kann was ich
noch habe ich möchte auch mal eben einen
haken eben war so die formulierung dann
braucht es keine hausspitze mehr oder
keine hospizbewegung linie ich glaube
die frage war nur muss man doch muss man
zwingend ins hospiz gegner aber in jedem
jahr nochmal auch anlagen genau
umgekehrt gesprochen wird glaube ich
quasi ein politischer auftrag daraus
ihren gedanken noch mal stärker homogene
zu verfolgen weil ich glaube dass sie
schon die hospizbewegung die wir jetzt
seit über 25 jahren in deutschland haben
dass sie schon stellvertretend dafür
steht wieder zu kultivieren in unserer
gesellschaft zu sorgen für einander und
zwar jenseits von altersgrenzen junge
menschen wie ältere menschen
wir haben ganz viele junge menschen die
in dieses ehrenamt auch streben sich
dafür qualifizieren wollen
und diese haltung die da wächst der
sorge um einander des sich bemühens um
einander ich glaube das ist politisch
gesehen gibt total große
gesellschaftliche aufgabe die wir jetzt
noch stellen müssen um das zu füllen und
um auch die nöte noch mal von der
anderen seite zu beantworten
eine userin die uns vor abgeschrieben
hat julia hertel schreibt ich arbeite in
der altenpflege und bin immer wieder
erschrocken wie viele menschen in ihren
letzten jahren noch leiden müssen weil
ihnen ein würdevoller abgang durch
sterbehilfe verweigert wird
und sie schreibt mehr aber sie fragt
dann ist es würde von einem menschen
erklären zu müssen dass die einzige
option sterben zu können
die des hungerstreiks ist weil sich die
politik verstellt ich persönlich bin pro
sterbehilfe durch geschultes personal
geschulte ärzte so viele länder machen
es uns vor dann werden wir es auch
endlich einsehen und im grunde mit dem
tag heute kann man sagen das
verfassungsgericht hat es hat sie erhört
und die rechtslage ist geändert aber
eben nur zum teil und vielleicht muss es
weitere änderungen geben ja das
verfassungsgericht hat nur einen stein
aus dem weg geräumt wenn man so will den
para und 217 der die wiederholte
beihilfe zum suizid unter strafe
gestellt hat aber alle anderen
gesetzlichen bestimmungen rechtlichen
bestimmungen sind zunächst mal
unangetastet weil sie gar nicht
verfahrensgegenstand war eine userin
schreibt hat uns vorab geschrieben dass
sie die gefahr also ich zitiere ich sehe
die gefahr darin dass alte oder kranke
menschen wenn die sterbehilfe erlaubt
ist das gefühl bekommen den angehörigen
nur zu last zu fallen und die pflicht
hätten nun diese hilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen
aktuell sind es einzelfälle die sich
dringend wünschen zu sterben aber wenn
es erlaubt ist es wird es dann eventuell
zur normalität oder er vielleicht zu
einer erwartungshaltung dass wir ab
einem gewissen punkt im leben selbst
gehen möchten müssen
das ist das was ich eben schon
angesprochen habe und es ist nicht aus
der luft gegriffen bei mir durchaus auch
auf die hospizliche bewegungen aus den
nachbarländern wissen dass es patienten
gibt die sagen was muss ich tun wie kann
ich zu euch in die region kommen in die
deutsche region damit ich nicht klar wie
die das risiko eingehen muss dass man
angst wieder schon anbietet und das
halte ich für so verzerrt und so
verworren
das sind situationen die wir erleben das
ist nichts was ich mir ausdenke und ich
glaube das ist hat muss signalwirkung
haben
das ist genau darum nicht geht was diese
userin schreibt was sagen sie da wie
kann es in ausnahmefällen sie sicherlich
sind das ausnahmefälle aber auch um die
muss ich ja politik und und und der
rechtsstaat kümmern und hat ab jetzt was
sagen sie wie kann das gelingen also
dass man das verhindert das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja heute
nur gesagt dass der staat nicht
berechtigt ist die motive des
suizidwilligen zu hinterfragen ihre
vernünftigkeit überprüfen
aber selbstverständlich kann jeder
einzelne arzt für sich entscheiden
akzeptiere ich die motive die der
betroffene hat die er mir offen äußert
und kann ich aufgrund dieser basis mit
meinem gewissen vereinbaren ihm ein
tödlich wirkendes medikament zur
verfügung zu stellen
also es ist nicht so dass die
ärzteschaft oder sonst irgendwelche
menschen jetzt regelhaft das anbieten
müssen schon gar nicht von sich aus
einem ein arzt sollte das auch nicht von
sich aus anbieten sondern nur wenn ein
suizid villiger zu ihnen kommen sondern
offen mit ihm redet dann auf in dem
gespräch in dem hoffentlich
vertrauensvollen gespräch auch darauf
ist ja auch ähnlich beim
schwangerschaftsabbruch auch da ist der
arzt ja frei zu entscheiden ob er den
vornimmt oder nicht genau das auch noch
zu der bemerkung von einer der userinnen
die vorhin ja geschrieben hatte sie
zitiert haben dass die ärzte einen eid
geschworen haben das leben zu bewahren
ja dass erstens haben sie keinen eid
geschworen aber das ist nur eine
kleinigkeit
natürlich sind die ärzte dem leben
verpflichtet aber der
schwangerschaftsabbruch ist auch nicht
lebensbejahend jedenfalls nicht für das
kind also insofern es gibt durch
brechungen dieses grundsatzes herz zu
schützen das leben aber in wohl
begründeten ausnahmen sollten sie von
diesem grundsatz abweichen
kontraproduktiv weil wir heute gehört
haben der würdevolle tod zum leben auch
dazu gehört also so hat das
verfassungsgericht auch gesagt
reinhard jantzen schreibt uns auf
facebook was ist wenn ich vor einer
demenz ein testament zum suizid mache
das nützt gar nichts denn der
suizidwillige damit ein suizid im
rechtssinne vorliegt und der andere der
dabei hilft nur der gehilfe ist beim
suizid der suizid willige muss im
tatzeitpunkt in dem die tötungshandlung
vollzogen werden muss rbb gerissen sagen
die tatherrschaft haben das heißt er
muss eigenverantwortlich die
entscheidung treffen jetzt möchte ich
mich töten und das ist wenn ein eine
voraus verfügung geschrieben wird dann
zwar zum zeitpunkt der voraus verfügung
der fall aber nicht mehr zu dem
zeitpunkt zu dem das tödlich wirkende
medikamente eingenommen wird in diesem
moment sowie der user schreibt ist der
betroffene nicht mehr
eigenverantwortlich tätig selbstbestimmt
tätig und das wäre kein suizid sondern
das wäre eine fremd tötung wenn jemand
ihm jetzt den gift becher hinstellen
würde und erinnern ist mehr oder weniger
geistig verwirrt ein zusätzlicher im
grunde beantworteten die frage der
nächsten er userin kesselmeier fragt
über youtube meine frage ist kann man in
einer patientenverfügung in diesem thema
eine vorsorge treffen für den fall dass
man dem ntc wird
man kann vorsorge treffen indem man
lebenserhaltende maßnahmen ablehnt also
man kann das angebot das die ärzte
machen wir können dein leben noch
verlängern
dieses andere davon ablehnen dann stirbt
man an seiner krankheit aber was nicht
erlaubt ist dass man mit hilfe einer
patientenverfügung einen eingriff von
außen also die zuführung tödlich
wirkenden medica eines tödlich wirkenden
medikaments veranlasst oder legitimiert
das geht nicht
ein umbau auf youtube fragt frage die
runde wie ist das denn nun bei unheilbar
kranken unheilbar kranken minderjährigen
die sterben wollen wie zum beispiel in
belgien oder in die niederlande
wie kann man sowas bewerten also muss es
dann oder hat das gericht hat eine
altersgrenze vorgesehen nein das war
auch nicht verfahrensgegenstand weil
dieser paragraph 217 keine altersgrenze
enthält wir haben das
patientenverfügungsgesetz das sagt ein
minderjährige kann keine bindende
rechtlich bindende patientenverfügung
verfassen
also wenn ein 17-jähriger schreibt ich
möchte keine lebenserhaltenden maßnahmen
dann kann das nicht in einer voraus
verfügung festgelegt werden
wenn man diese überlegungen hier auf
unsere situation überträgt dann würde
man sagen dass auch ein minderjähriger
keine beihilfe zum suizid apple darf
aber nach allgemeinen medizin
rechtlichen grundsätzen kann ein
minderjähriger sehr wohl wenn er ein
bildungs fähig ist man geht im
allgemeinen so ab 16 jahren von 1
bewegungsfähigkeit aus kann also ein
minderjähriger eine eigene entscheidung
treffen welche medizinische behandlung
bei ihm durchgeführt werden darf und er
kann sie dann auch verweigern und
jedenfalls die meisten juristen sagen
das betrifft dann auch lebenserhaltende
maßnahmen aber das ist ein grauer endung
das feld da gibt es keine klaren
rechtlichen regeln da kann man keine
klare aussage treffen was ein gericht in
einem solchen fall sagen würde
denn viele juristen sagen auch um das
noch anzufügen dass bei minderjährigen
immer auch die eltern mit entscheiden
müssen
ein so genannter coco minderjährigen und
erwachsenen notwendig ist also ein unser
recht unsicher das gebiet zusammen zu
viel hat man fragt auf facebook da hat
mir auch darüber gesprochen ist die
änderung des betäubungsmittelgesetzes
nun zwangsläufig gegeben oder was könnte
man tun dass es zügig angepasst wird
also was kann man tun damit es zügig
angepackt habe der gesetzgeber muss
tätig werden oder es müsste irgendein
gericht war
die normen sowie die herkömmlicherweise
ausgelegt werden sind mit dem
grundgedanken dieser entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nicht
vereinbar
und deswegen müssen wir die vorschriften
wir als gericht diese vorschrift anders
auslegen das ist möglich nur ist es
nicht so wenn obersten bundesgerichts
entscheidung treffen dass einzelfall
entscheidungen haben die
allgemeingültigkeit und weiterhin können
sie sich eine bundesbehörde auf den
standpunkt stellen
wir folgen dem nicht richtig also nicht
auch das ist ja auch gelten das geltende
lage das bundesverwaltungsgericht hat er
vor einiger zeit geurteilt dass bei
unerträglichen light eine staatliche
behörde das sogenannte b fahren
ein tödlich wirkendes medikament zur
verfügung stellen muss das galt aber nur
für den kläger der damals geklagt hat
der inzwischen verstorben ist und dieses
urteil entfaltet keine rechtlich
bindende wirkung für andere fälle und
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
ja auch das bva angewiesen diese
entscheidung nicht auf andere in anderen
fällen anzuwenden also das bfm hat über
100 anträge vor sich liegen bei sich
liegen und entscheidet einfach nicht
darüber 40 hoffentlich ändern
ich möchte danke schön sagen vor allem
an sie sie haben uns wirklich zahlreich
geschrieben sich bei uns gemeldet vorab
und mit sehr klugen mit sehr
differenzierten ansichten mit sehr
persönlichen erfahrungen dafür möchte
ich ihnen danken und ein großes
dankeschön an diese runde für ihre
expertise und vor allem an sie herr
feldmann dass sie heute hier mit uns
live das urteil folgt und eingeschätzt
haben es war unglaublich wertvoll ihre
erfahrung zu hören weil das ist ihr
urteil das sie erstritten haben deshalb
noch mal glückwunsch nochmal und vielen
dank dass sie hier mit in der runde
waren vielen dank an alle und schönen
tag